I want to leave you with
this one last little story.
This story about
the moments before
before my day of
reckoning, really, okay?
On our last expedition, I came
down off this mountain top
and these trucks
pulled up to our camp.
And they were shamans.
There were these seven shamans
who had showed up at the
base of the Burkhan Khaldun
this mountain to
pay tribute to...
Genghis Khan.
And Professor Ishdorj comes
to me and he goes, "Albert...
the head shaman wants to see
the leader of our group."
( audience laughter )
I was like, "Oh, shoot!"
This is the moment
before, you know
I've a little bit of
video, not a lot.
( speaking in Mongolian )
I can't say
I'm not nervous.
I'm terrified, okay!
Like, what's going
to happen here.
And these guys are
running around preparing,
and you've got that arrow, you
know, pointed up at the mountain
and the shaman is putting
on, you know, his gown.
And what else could I do...
( sound of pounding
on rustic drums )
You know, you couldn't
even see his face
because he was covered in
this black, this black felt
that wouldn't allow
you to see his eyes.
But he had these big eyeballs
painted on to his headband
and these huge feathers...
these huge massive
feathers that went from
you know, above his
headband into the sky.
And he had these massive
dreadlock-like things
flapping around him as
the pounding got
more and more intense.
Boom, boom, boom over my head
and my heart started pounding
with the same rhythm
underneath him
as he is pounding over my
head and I'm literally stuck
like a stone to the
ground, terrified.
( sound of pounding
on rustic drums )
And then it just stops.
( sound of pounding
on rustic drums )
And he falls to the ground
you know, he just
sort of collapses.
And he just asks me these
really simple questions, like
"what's your name,
when were you born..."
You know, then he asked me
"why am I here?"
And I'm sitting there and I'm...
And I tried to give this great
explanation, you know, like
the whole deal with the
technology and the search
and why we're doing
it all, and...
you know, it's a
long explanation and it gets
translated into Mongolian and
a little bit gets lost there.
By the time it gets
to the attendant
who is translating it from
Mongolian to ancient Mongolian
it's like one or two words,
you know.
( audience laughter )
And...
I'm like, "Wow, didn't
really work out."
And I am sitting there
and the shaman just
he doesn't even care,
you know.
And he starts talking, he
was like, "it doesn't matter
about the technology," he says.
He says,
"I was sent here
by my own soul to try to
know more about my past.
And it's my intentions
that matter."
And he says, "Go off and tell
the world about this story.
And then your intentions
will be true.
For you will have
followed through with
what you told me."
You know.
"Stay true to your traditions,
stay true to your honor
but do this, tell the
story of our mountain."
So, today I am standing
around you, you know
at the National Geographic
headquarters
years after I launched
this project
which has totally
changed my life.
And you are just
so deeply in my heart...
the edge of that journey,
the continuing part of that.
You are the reason
why I did it all.
And now you are part
of that whole story.
So, thank you very much.
( applause )